non bonjour à tous merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne une table ronde
organisée par la commission de la
culture du sénat sur le thème comment
concilier liberté d'internet et
rémunération des créateurs
objectif de cette table ronde rester un
bilan de la lutte contre le piratage
depuis la mise en place d'hadopi cette
table ronde intervient alors que nicolas
sarkozy a annoncé en novembre dernier
qu'il souhaitait étendre la législation
contre le piratage aux sites de
streaming
ces sites en flux continu qui permettent
donc de visionner des images sans
téléchargement ne sont en effet
actuellement pas visés par la
législation d'hadopi tout de suite donc
direction la salle clémenceau bonne
matinée à tous je vous remercie de votre
présence
c'est une demi journée des changes que
je souhaite apaiser et fructueuse
permettez-moi d'abord de former des
voeux pour chacun d'entre vous en ce
début d'année 2012 qui sera riche en
arbitrage n'en doutons pas quelles que
soient vos convictions et les choix
électoraux des français nous sommes dans
un exercice politique démocratique
imaginez le maire d'un village qui voit
la population âgée lui réclamer des
bancs ils les installe et puis la
population âgée vient le voir est dit
mais c'est dégoûtant ya toujours les
jeunes qui s'installent dessus prennent
les places ils s'embrassent c'est pas
possible qu'il l'ait désinstalle et puis
d'autres personnes âgées viennent mais
dit c'est pas possible on ne peut plus
s'asseoir il les réinstalle ce rôle de
politique nous ne souhaitons pas
l'exécuter nous ne sommes pas des
girouettes
nous souhaitons installer le dialogue
entre personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
les mêmes stratégies pour défendre le
bien commun ou leurs intérêts c'est dans
cet esprit de dialogue que je souhaite
que se déroulent ces tableront
voilà un an notre commission avait déjà
organisé un travail sur les conditions
du développement de la création de
contenus culturels à l'heure du
numérique
aujourd'hui nous voulons approfondir les
réflexions alors que les défis de la
deuxième révolution numérique se
précisent de même que l'urgence allait
relever comment garantir la rémunération
des créateurs sans brider les échanges
et la créativité sur internet
si cette question est ici à nouveau
posée c'est que les dispositions
aujourd'hui en vigueur ne donne pas
toute satisfaction
les protagonistes du contrôle des
téléchargements et des sanctions par la
loi davezies se sont d'ailleurs il y a
quelques années très vite rendu compte
de son inapplicabilité tandis que les
défenseurs des droits du consommateur
rejoignez les rangs indignés des
défenseurs des libertés publiques la
démesure des sanctions montrait bien que
les intérêts en jeu dépassé ceux des
simples créateur de plus certains
éditeurs qui montrait hier du doigt la
spoliation des auteurs n'ont pas été les
derniers au travers de plates formes
inédites et de forfaits peu regardants à
flouer les principes qu'il m'était hier
en avant souvenez vous la très contestée
licence globale dont je mesure à la fois
l'intérêt potentiel si elle n'avait pas
été diabolisé avant même d'avoir été
sérieusement étudiée mais dont je mesure
le problème de rupture culturelle est
dommageable qu'elle posait en brisant le
lien direct auteur oeuvre rémunération
la fameuse licence globale retrouver
paradoxalement à cette époque sous
couvert d'offre alléchante un
travestissement à but lucratif comme si
le marché prenait acte des moeurs en
cours et sautez soudain le ruisseau de
l'éthique qu'ils mettaient en avant pour
défendre ses intérêts puis vient hadopi
plus consensuel le texte n'en fut pas
moins partiel
non censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel en juin 2009
je me souviens de ce départ motivé par
la défense des créateurs mais au cours
duquel je vous le rappelle on vit un
cavalier soutenu par le gouvernement qui
disait que toute production textes ou
photos d'un journaliste ne méritait pas
rémunération pour que cette duplication
interviennent sur un support appartenant
au même groupe de presse
quand on connaît la concentration des
médias
il fut pour le moins curieux qu'une loi
prétendant défendre les auteurs en
deviennent pour partie fossoyeur
personnellement je ne me laisse pas
d'interroger sur un système dans lequel
c'est à l'accusé de faire preuve de son
innocence et dans lequel prouver son
innocence peut consister à donner les
preuves de l'achat et de l'installation
de dispositifs pare feu lié à une
filière économique incompatible avec le
logiciel libre nous entendrons donc le
premier bilan qu'en tirent la présidente
d'hadopi les plateformes les canaux de
distribution les appareils connectés à
internet se multiplient parallèlement
nous assistons à une révolution des
modes de création de diffusion et aussi
de consommation des biens culturels
la distribution des contenus culturels
est à la fois plus complexe mondialisée
de plus en plus concentrée ce quelques
grands opérateurs mais aussi protéiforme
le développement des réseaux sociaux de
la lecture en flux streaming la forme
l'info nuage ou cloud computing et la
télévision connectée viennent
bouleverser les principes et avec elle
les modèles économiques dans ce contexte
on a entendu au forum d'avignon en
novembre 2011 que la propriété
intellectuelle est un concept de plus en
plus volatile
notre commission n'a pas l'intention de
la laisser s'évaporer
il nous faut aujourd'hui prendre de la
hauteur et posé
sérieusement les bases du cadre public
que nous voulons donner aux pratiques
liées à l'évolution des supports de
communication et des changes
notre priorité c'est la culture la
création les savoirs leur production
leurs échanges universitaires et
artistes militants et chercheurs tous
mesurent aujourd'hui la formidable
contribution des outils numériques et de
la toile à la résolution d un jeu
d'aujourd'hui et de demain ainsi que
leur aspect collaboratif voix solidaires
nous entendrons par la bouche de
monsieur jean bergevin responsable de la
lutte contre la contrefaçon et le
piratage à la commission européenne si
l'europe prépare la mise en adéquation
de ses priorités et la garantie de la
non spoliation des créateurs dans le
journal le monde du 3 janvier 2012 des
intellectuels averti faisait proposition
de transformer hadopi en conteur des
flux pour calculer le droit des artistes
lors de sa venue à paris richard
stallman défendez le mécénat global la
traduction trop simplifié devenait vite
une redistribution d'une partie des
fonds recueillis selon la popularité des
oeuvres on enterrait une deuxième fois
cesaria evora personnellement je ne
m'accommode pas que l'identification des
plus populaires mais taupe à sec les
oeuvres qu'ils mettent plus de temps à
se faire reconnaître ou qui rencontrent
un public plus les trois la diversité
culturelle ne doit pas être un vain mot
et il est du devoir des pouvoirs publics
d'en garantir la richesse
la matinée est organisé entre watts tout
d'abord un état des lieux de la
protection du droit d'auteur sur
internet et des réponses juridiques
actuellement mises en oeuvre ou
envisagés en france en europe aux etats
unis le deuxième temps à une évaluation
de l'efficacité de ces réponses
nous entendrons temps la présidente de
l'hadopi que les détracteurs de la loi
puis les ayants droit
enfin nous tournerons nos regards vers
l'avenir les mutations en cours doivent
nous permettre à la fois de créer les
opportunités d'accroître l'accès de tous
aux productions culturelles et de
trouver des moyens pérennes d'améliorer
la transparence et l'équité du
financement de la création
les nouvelles technologies elle même
pourrait y contribuer de nouvelles
sources de financement sont encore à
imaginer à mettre en oeuvre une remarque
préalable s'agisse un des participants à
la table ronde
nous avions souhaité tous les secteurs
soient représentés je vous signale
simplement que les représentants des
ayants droit du monde de la musique
sacem snap mais également la d'amis se
sont désistés l'a dit compte tenu de
réunion simultanée de la mission lancée
par le ministre de la culture pour
préfigurer le futur centre national de
la musique et simultanément la
commission pour la copie privée
bon je regrette quand même qu'il ne se
soit pas fait représenter
je vous rappelle que cette table ronde
est ouverte à la presse ou
professionnels concernés elle sera
enregistrée diffusée sur la chaîne
public sénat
vous la retrouverez sur le site internet
du sénat
je propose que chaque intervenant
dispose de cinq minutes d'intervention
avant que ne s'engage le débat avec les
sénateurs et la salle je suis sûr que
les souhaits d'intervention et les
questions ne manqueront pas mais je
propose que nous commencions par évoquer
l'état des lieux de la protection du
droit d'auteur sur internet et nous
allons entendre de suite pour le cadre
juridique français
monsieur christophe à l'homme professeur
de droit et lui la pav que cinq minutes
voilà donc merci madame la présidente de
me passer la parole pour un tout petit
peu plus de cinq minutes mais dans un
temps qui sera très court
c'est certain alors le cadre juridique
français donc moi je suis dans l'état
des lieux je vais présenter le droit
positif et je ne pense pas apprendre
beaucoup de choses à ceux qui
s'intéressent aux droits d'auteur sur
internet aujourd'hui mais peut-être pour
mettre un petit peu les choses en
perspective la question qui est posée
c'est le thème de la journée c'est
comment concilier la liberté de
l'internet et la rémunération des
créateurs
en tout cas cette feuille qui était
distribué lors de l'habitation concilier
liberté rémunération liberté donc droit
d'auteur ça semble déjà prendre position
sur le fait qu'il y à une opposition
parfois entre les deux et c'est bien
cette opposition que le législateur à
mon sens tente de régler depuis un
certain nombre d'années français mais
européen européen ça a commencé avec la
directive de 2001 que vous avez rappelé
madame la présidente
en france assez traduit d'abord par la
loi que vous avez cité également la loi
du 1er août 2006 la loi dadvsi d'avsi
droits d'auteur droits voisins dans la
société de l'information
et comme vous l'avez dit également ça
s'est poursuivi avec les deux lois
hadopi de 2009
de mon point de vue donc de
d'universitaires et de juristes il me
semble que ces deux textes tentent de
parvenir à un équilibre alors ils sont
ils parvenus chacun aura une idée là
dessus
ces deux textes tentent de parvenir à un
équilibre entre la liberté d'un côté et
les droits d'auteur de l'autre il faut
dire que l'objectif de protection du
droit d'auteur est une contrainte pour
la france puisque la france est liée par
un certain nombre de conventions
internationales la france a l'obligation
de transposer les directives de l'union
européenne et qu'elle est engagée à
l'égard des autres et à assurer le
respect du droit d'auteur sur son
territoire je ne vais pas rappeler les
textes mais chose il faudrait au moins
citer les plus importants encore apic
1994 ou déjà l'on parle de la question
des autos de l'information donc de
l'internet pour parler comme vous
puis les conventions de genève de 1996
on pourrait citer la convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme et des libertés fondamentales en
tout cas le protocole numéro un qui fait
du droit d'auteur un droit de propriété
et le droit de propriété est protégée
comme un droit fondamental
et puis je n'ose citer toutes les
directives qui se sont succédé 1992 mais
toutes vont dans le même sens protéger
les droits d'auteurs protéger la
propriété littéraire artistique les
droits voisins etc
mais la france a également l'obligation
de protéger les libertés et bien sûr les
libertés alors vous avez parlé de
consommateurs je parlerai d'internautes
mais on va finalement désigné la même
réalité avec ces deux mots la france a
l'obligation de protéger les libertés
puisque elle est liée par des textes de
non moins important à nouveau la
convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme et des libertés des
libertés fondamentales liberté de
l'information par exemple mais également
par des textes de valeur
constitutionnelle la déclaration des
droits de l'homme bien sûr et quand le
conseil constitutionnel a censuré
l'une des lois que vous avez cités
s'étaient bien sur le fondement de
l'article 11 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme en faisant du droit
d'accès à l'internet un droit
fondamental
et puis il ya la déclaration universelle
prises dans le cadre de l'onu 1948 et
puis un certain nombre d'autres textes
donc il faut et c'est une mission
difficile à la fois protéger la
propriété et maintenir les libertés
est-ce que cet équilibre où cette
conciliation a été acté a été atteinte
par le législateur avec les textes que
vous avez cités bien sûr aucun travail
législatif n'est parfait il me semble
quand même que depuis 2006 les lois
françaises puisqu'il y en a eu plusieurs
ont réussi d'une part à étendre la
liberté de l'internet et là j'aurais pas
tout à fait la même approche que celle
que vous avez vues concernant la loi
davdsi étendre la liberté de l'internet
maintenir une protection du droit
d'auteur loi hadopi on va en parler dans
un instant tout ceci passant par une
responsabilisation de l'internaute et il
me semble que ce sont ces trois
objectifs qui sont poursuivis par le
législateur depuis 2006 c'est à dire
depuis l'année où l'on a commencé
transposé la directive de 2001 donc de
mon point de vue la loi française a un
triple objectif liberté propriété
responsabilités et je souhaiterais on
expliqué liberté pour quoi
et bien parce que je le disais la loi
dadvsi a effectivement créé l'obligation
de vigilance de l'internaute ce à quoi
vous faisiez allusion mais elle a
également multiplié les exceptions au
droit d'auteur et il ne faut pas le
perdre de vue
or assez régulièrement ces exceptions
nouvelles n'ont pas été compensés pour
les auteurs moi j'ai regardé très
rapidement les nouvelles exceptions qui
résulte de la loi davdsi nouvelles
exceptions donc en 2006 dit pédagogique
je rentre pas dans le détail et la celle
ci est compensée nouvelles exceptions
dit de copie technique pour permettre la
circulation des oeuvres sur internet
donc toutes les actes de reproduction
pour faire simple qui vont être
nécessaires à la circulation d'une
oeuvre échappe au monopole de l'auteur
nouvelles exceptions faveur des
établissements accueillant des
handicapés jeudi handicapée pour aller
vite c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
mais c'est quand même sa nouvelle
exception en faveur des bibliothèques
des musées des autres archives qui
peuvent copier les oeuvres pour
maintenir un certain nombre de copies et
qui peuvent ainsi permettre à leurs
usagers d'accéder plus facilement aux
oeuvres sans renouveler leur stock n'est
pas forcément une très bonne nouvelle
pour les livrets pour les libraires ou
les éditeurs et nouvelle exception en
faveur de la presse possibilité de
rendre compte d'un certain nombre
d'oeuvres c'était que problématique
autrefois mais dont la donc ici cinq
nouvelles exceptions une seule à ma
connaissance est compensé par une
rémunération négocier au maintien les
exceptions traditionnel on en crée cinq
nouvelles or ceci se passe j'insiste
bien sans compensation systématique des
auteurs c'est intéressant parce que lors
des débats parlementaires et vous le
savez dans cette assemblée notamment
l'absence de compensation des auteurs
avaient été mises en avant par le fait
que les nouvelles exceptions était
justifiée par l'intérêt général
personne n'est contre je pense
l'exception de pédagogie personne n'est
contre
l'exception permettant aux handicapés de
prendre plus facilement connaissance des
oeuvres etc
il y a sans doute un intérêt général
mais je constate que l'absence de
mesures de compensation fait que la
perte de revenus créés par ces
exceptions et supporter assez souvent
parler seul sauteur qui sont donc les
contributeurs de l'intérêt général ou de
la solidarité nationale
donc ça c'est un point que je mets en
avant parce que la loi davdsi
effectivement elle responsabilise
internautes
j'y reviendrai dans un instant bien sûr
avec l'obligation de vigilance mais elle
crée ses nouvelles exceptions et la
multiplication des exceptions nouvelle
pour moi est une
un acte qui permet de donner du sens à
la liberté alors sur internet et pas
seulement sur internet mais sur internet
en partie alors ceci étant dit
effectivement liberté responsabilité on
voit bien ces deux notions ces deux
objectifs à paraître dans la loi davdsi
je dirais que les lois hadopi met plutôt
en avant les la propriété et la
responsabilité le respect de la
propriété et le respect de la
responsabilité
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que la loi les lois hadopi il faut ne
pas les séparer les lois hadopi viennent
donner un contenu à l'obligation de
vigilance qui avait été consacré par la
loi de 2006 mais qui à l'époque ne
comportait pas de sanction
7 ce contenu concret de l'obligation de
vigilance et la réponse graduée dont
marie françoise marais la présidente
parlera j'imagine dans un instant mais
il n'ya pas que cela dans les lois
hadopi effectivement la réponse graduée
est souvent ce qui ressort dans la
presse est ce que le grand public a
retenu des lois hadopi moi il ya deux
choses qui m'intéressent
en plus c'est la mission de
labellisation de l'hadopi et la mission
d'encouragement à la mise en place d'une
offre légale
la labellisation
la propriété est donc la rémunération
des auteurs pour reprendre le thème qui
ne retient aujourd'hui donc il y a dans
les lois hadopi de la responsabilité
l'internaute est averti une fois deux
fois la troisième fois à l'hadopi
transmis le dossier et vous savez qu'ils
encourent une sanction alors qu'il n'est
plus celle de la contrefaçon enfin ça
n'est pas l'objectif de la loi en tout
cas mais une suspension de son
abonnement internet
donc il y à une sanction de toute façon
si l'internaute n'est pas vigilant mais
ne perdons pas de vue que les deux
autres missions de l'hadopi que j'ai
cités labellisation encouragement à la
mise en place d'une offre légale sont
véritablement de nature à donner un sens
à la propriété est me semble-t-il
je peux me tromper sont conformes à la
tente des internautes qui se plaignent
en tout cas dans les journaux en ligne
papier que l'on peut tous lire de
l'insuffisance aujourd'hui peut-être de
sites sur deux sites certains ou de
sites facilement identifiables
la généralisation d'une offre légale et
donc de mon point de vue conforme aux
attentes des internautes et devrait
permettre au droit de propriété de
prospérer de prospérer une fois réglé le
problème pour l'internaute de
l'identification effectivement de ces
sites vous savez que je parle mais
françoise marais est à mes côtés elle me
contredira si je me trompe que la
labellisation est octroyé le label est
octroyée aux sites légaux un site légal
c'est pas toujours un site payant
il ya des sites payants illégaux il ya
des sites gratuits légaux il y à des
sites rémunérateur des auteurs mais qui
ne sont pas en tout cas aujourd'hui
labellisés et il est vrai qu'il est
extrêmement difficile pour l'internaute
moyen de s'y retrouver
que peut-il télécharger sans courir le
risque de la sanction que peut-il
consulter sans encourir le risque de la
sanction c'est pas forcément
parfaitement clair pour lui
donc ces deux missions labellisation et
puis encouragement à la mise en oeuvre
d'une à la mise en place d'une offre
légale me semble quand même intéressante
pour le respect du droit de propriété
tout en maintenant les libertés
évidemment des internautes alors
dernière chose parce que j'ai dit que je
ne serai pas long mais deux dernières
choses pour conclure mon propos
j'ai pu constater au fil des conférences
ou des rencontres après tout je suis
chaque jour dans mon université avec des
étudiants est assez souvent il
m'interroge sur la question je suis
confronté à deux de réserve
effectivement concernant le dispositif
législatif mis en place tout cas on me
fait part de réserves de questions me
sont régulièrement poser la première
question concerne la responsabilité
d'autres personnes que l'internaute il
est vrai qu'à l'heure actuelle c'est
l'internaute qui est le principal
responsable désigné par la loi c'est lui
que l'on avertisse et lui qui encourt la
sanction un certain nombre d'entre eux
me semble-t-il ont le sentiment d'être
un peu le bouc émissaire en tout cas des
deux lois hadopi et un certain nombre
d'internautes s'interroge sur la
désignation d'autres responsables que
même
évidemment il pense aux plateformes
d'hébergement alors je ne dis pas qu'ils
sont tour la responsabilisation des
plateformes d'hébergement mais on se dit
mais est ce que c'est bien toujours
l'internaute qui mérite
tout est la seule attention du
législateur la deuxième question c'est
celle de la licence mais comme on m'a
demandé de m'en tenir au droit positif
et l'enjeu n'en parlerait que peu mais
je tiens quand même à en dire un mot
alors sur la responsabilité des
plateformes d'hébergement ou des
prestataires techniques
est-ce qu'il faut plus de
responsabilités sur le droit français à
l'heure actuelle permet d'engager plus
facilement responsabilités vous le savez
tous la loi du 21 juin 2004 qui a
transposé la directive du 8 juin 2000 a
retenu a mis en place un système de
responsabilité allégée des hébergeurs
notamment mais pas seulement
ceux ci sont responsables s'ils ne
réagissent pas promptement lorsque on
leur a signalé un contenu illicite de ce
qui veut dire que les ayants droit qui
constate qu'une oeuvre est proposée au
téléchargement par exemple alors que la
plateforme n'a pas reçu l'autorisation
c'est ayants droit doit informer la
plateforme la plateforme retire
l'oeuvre est malheureusement elle
revient quelques heures après mais c'est
le système
finalement qui est retenu aujourd'hui
les informations que j'aime a dit que
les plateformes d'hébergement jouent le
jeu retient les oeuvres quand on leur
demande de les retirer
le problème c'est qu'elles n'ont pas
l'obligation de suivi etc une oeuvre qui
a été retirée peut réapparaître sans que
la plateforme et d'elle même
l'obligation de de la retirer de la
suivre de la piste et je sais que tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord là dessus
mais la question qui est posée c'est de
savoir s'il faudrait passer d'un système
du nautisme tech donne système de
notices en stedo nous on va finalement
observer que les oeuvres que l'on a
retiré ne réapparaisse pas en l'état
actuel dès textes ça n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas possible et ça n'est
toujours pas bien compris par les
internautes qui se disent et votre
exemple avec les bancs publics
paraissent bon que si c'est sur internet
et si ça n'est pas retirer puisque c'est
là ça n'a pas été retirée c'est sans
doute qu'on a le droit de télécharger ça
rejoint le prime de la labellisation et
ça rejoint le problème de l'efficacité
finalement du nautisme tech donne alors
c'est la solution du droit français ou
pourra sans doute rang parlais tout à
l'heure je tiens à signaler mais encore
une fois un grand nombre d'entre vous le
savent déjà que les américains
s'orientent vers une responsabilité
beaucoup plus sévère des prestataires
techniques avec les projets de loi
so passe d'apple light bearer assise qui
permettrait au département de la justice
américain de poursuivre les sites
internet suspects et de distribuer du
contenu piraté ou dédié au piratage tout
dépend des traductions que vous aurez y
compris lorsqu'ils seraient situées hors
du territoire américain la justice sera
alors en mesure d'isoler ces sites
d'assécher financièrement ces sites en
les privant de leurs sources de revenus
ce qui passerait par des saisies
déblocage des comptes bancaires retrait
des publicités certaines mesures
contraignantes au niveau des moteurs de
recherche de référencement ou autre et
qui passerait également par des mesures
de contrainte à l'égard des fournisseurs
d'accès à internet je ne sais pas si ce
projet sera votée et sera discutée si
j'ai bien compris au sénat le 24 janvier
prochain
mais en l'état actuel cette solution
n'est pas possible sur le territoire
français je crois même qu'elles ne
seraient pas acceptées par nos
concitoyens qui tiennent effectivement
ce par quoi j'ai commencé c'est-à-dire
la liberté sur internet la liberté dans
le respect de la propriété
d'où la nécessité effectivement d'être
un petit peu plus clair sur ce qui est
licite et sur ce qui l'est moins c'est
pourquoi il me semble pour terminer sur
cette première remarque conclusive que
la coopération entre prestataires
techniques notamment pour l'efficacité
d'une notice en teck donne est sans
doute la mesure vers laquelle nous
devrions nous orienter
puisqu'il s'agit quand même d'une mesure
qui me semble plus acceptable compte
tenu de notre tradition je les dis qui
est de permettre la liberté mais dans le
respect de la propriété des autres quant
à la licence légale mais vraiment 30
secondes qui concilierait selon certains
la liberté de l'internet et la
rémunération des créateurs et me semble
qu'elle ne veut pas être abordée sans
régler trois questions préalables n'est
pas compétent ce mois pour répondre à
ces questions mais je commencerai par
celle du coup tour le contributeur
l'internaute j'imagine mais tout est
possible
celle du coup nous pouvons tous lire des
chiffres parfois faux lent parfois
rassurant je pense que dans les deux cas
on ne dit pas la vérité 10 euros 100
euros
150 j'en sais rien je suis peut-être
quelqu'un a la réponse ici mais cette
question là ne peut pas être éludée
deuxième observation sur la licence
légale pourquoi pas mais elle est tout
frais finalement les efforts du
législateur de la haute autorité des
professionnels depuis deux ans
finalement seulement consistant à mettre
en place une offre légale conforme me
semble-t-il aux attentes des citoyens
des internautes
pourquoi ne pas laisser sa chance et un
petit peu mon propos à ce qui est en
train de se passer alors si on commence
par la musique mais peut-être que madame
marie aura d'autres exemples à nous
donner
et puis troisième observation licence
égal ne règlerait pas selon moi la
question de l'usagé illicite des oeuvres
par des sites situés à l'étranger
enfin je ne sais pas mais j'ai
l'impression que si une loi a été votée
en ce sens elle ne serait applicable que
sur le territoire français alors on peut
toujours envisager comme les américains
ou comme on l'a fait nous mêmes pour le
livre numérique d'avoir des lois qui
s'appliquent au delà du territoire
français mais vous savez que la légalité
de ces dispositions peuvent être
extrêmement douteuse donc voilà j'espère
ne pas avoir abusé du temps vous m'avez
accordé madame la présidente ce que je
voulais dire liberté propriété mes
responsabilités de l'internaute ou
d'autres personnes liberté propriété
responsabilités ça me semble être un un
équilibre quand même acceptable compte
tenu du peu d'ancienneté des lois merci
monsieur l homme nous allons entendre un
deuxième exposé sur le cadre de la barre
de monsieur giuseppe de martino de
l'association des services internet
communautaires
merci madame la présidente je suis
également vice président du conseil
national du numérique
instauré par le chef de l'état mais je
vais interviendrait aujourd'hui quand on
président de l'asic donc l'association
des services internet communautaires
association unique au monde il n'y a
qu'en france que des grands groupes
américains google yahoo microsoft de
petits champions nationaux comme
dailymotion ou priceminister ou encore
des startups ont souhaité se regrouper
pour porter la bonne parole quelque part
c'est le thème de la conférence
d'aujourd'hui
oui internet est une chance pour
l'économie oui
internet est une chance pour la création
permettez moi également de débuter avec
une référence cinématographique nous
sommes en 2012 j'ai un peu l'impression
de revivre vous savez ce film un jour
sans fin le jour de la marmotte bien sur
internet et création peuvent vivre
ensemble
pourquoi en 2012 nous sommes obligés de
nous poser encore la question
on a dû de notre côté sur un raté
quelque chose comme l'a très bien exposé
le professeur à allonnes des textes
existent en france
ces textes peut-être rappelons leur
genèse nous avons la chance ce matin
d'avoir jean bergevin autour de cette
table sa parole est d'or donc je ne me
permettrais pas de dévoiler ce qu'il va
dire mais rappelons nous quand même la
fin des années 2000 qu'est ce que la fin
des années 2000 en europe et internet
c'est une amy gémonies total des acteurs
américains à bruxelles on se dit qu'il
faut aider les acteurs économiques
européens à franchir le rubicon à
exister sur internet
douze ans après treize ans après
peut-être que l'hégémonie américaine
existe encore mais au moins des acteurs
européens ont pu se lancer ont pu
exister et quelle est cette directive et
pardon de le rappeler ces directives
n'est pas une directive sur le droit
cette directive n'est pas une directive
sur le droit d'auteur c'est une
directive sur le commerce électronique
il faut que les acteurs européens
prennent ce risque sans avoir un risque
trop important à savoir une
responsabilité a priori quant à leurs
activités
par contre leur responsabilité est quand
même importante puisqu'elle est a
posteriori
même chose pour la transposition de
cette directive là aussi en france et
transport
là aussi ce n'est pas un texte sur le
droit un texte sur le droit d'auteur
c'est la loi pour la confiance dans
l'économie numérique c'est exactement le
thème
de cette conférence il faut avoir une
confiance totale dans le sens de
l'histoire
les plateformes communautaires les
services communautaires comme l'a très
bien exprimé le professeur alleaume ont
une obligation
forte de réagir promptement donc à
posteriori cela va de soi les textes
sont clairs je suis à mes heures perdues
également secrétaire général de
dailymotion dailymotion société
française on a coutume de dire que de la
france pour dailymotion c'est 10 % de
notre audience et 100% de aux ennuis 1
pourquoi il n'ya qu'en france au nom de
l'exception culturelle
on a remis en cause l'existence même de
sites internet voulant tendre la main au
monde de la création
ces paroles sont sans doute un petit peu
forte mais représente quand même le
parcours de combattant qu'on a dû
franchir en france alors que dans tous
les autres pays
un tapis rouge nous a été déroulé dans
tous les autres pays
il était clair que nos services étaient
au final au service de la création et je
me souviens de nombreuses réunions à
bruxelles avec les collègues de monsieur
bergevin notamment ou en expliquant que
la cour de cassation dont l'organe la
cour suprême d'un état membre avait dû
se positionner sur le statut de services
comme les nôtres c'est une anomalie
s'est il n'y a qu'en france qu'on a
ressenti le besoin d'aller jusqu'au plus
haut de l'appareil judiciaire pour
confirmer quelque chose qui était clair
dans l'esprit de tous les autres états
membres
mais je passe comment au quotidien
comment en pratique nous appliquons ces
principes de responsabilité a posteriori
comment nous tendons la main comment
nous pensons qu'il est possible de
concilier liberté de l'internet avec la
rémunération des créateurs et le droit
sacré de la propriété intellectuelle
il ya une espèce de soumah division il y
a les auteurs les ayants droit qui ne
souhaitent pas travailler avec nous et
il ya les auteurs les ayants droit qui
souhaitent au contraire voir leurs
oeuvres présentes sur ses services
voyons tout d'abord ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas aujourd'hui travailler
avec nous et bien cela éclaire d'un
autre côté comme on l'a évoqué au
préalable il y a un appareil législatif
très bien fait qu permet sur la base
d'une notification envoyée aux
plateformes communautaires de procéder
au retrait de des contenus présupposés
contrefaisants chaque service chaque
plateforme communautaire à des équipes
24 heures sur 24 365 jours par an qui
sont là justement pour traiter ces
demandes
ensuite pour reprendre également ce qui
avait été dit sur le tecdax des darnes
les plateformes telles que youtube
dailymotion ont travaillé avec de
nombreux prestataires notamment france à
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
pour mettre en place des systèmes qu'on
appelle de fingerprinting dans de
reconnaissance des contenus qui
permettent au moment de la mise en ligne
de deux de n'importe quelle vidéo de il
ya plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
vidéos qui sont mises en ligne sur ses
services chaque jour chaque minute qui
passe plusieurs heures de contenus sont
mis en ligne et bien c'est ces contenus
sont quelque sorte scanner au moment de
leur mise en ligne on reconnaît six tonk
autres faisans ou pas une vraie
évolution là aussi entre la france et
les états unis
ces systèmes de fingerprinting aux etats
unis aujourd'hui sont utilisés non pas
pour bloquer la mise en ligne de
contenus mais pour les reconnaître et
monétiser ces contenus
en france on a encore quand un ayant
droit à l'obligeance de bien vous par
utiliser ces technologies qui sont
financés par par les plates formes elles
seules ces outils ne sont utilisés que
pour empêcher on ne veut pas voir les
créations protégés sur internet
ce qui est tout à fait compréhensible
mais qui encore une fois est pas bon
d'insister différent de l'évolution
qu'on voit poindre
aux états unis on peut aussi rappeler
que en parallèle
voilà nous interrompons cette
table-ronde vous pourrez la revoir en
intégralité très bientôt sur notre
chaîne mais aussi sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
à suivre les programmes de nos confrères
de lcp assemblée nationale la très belle
journée à tous
se renseigner sur les programmes voir ou
revoir les émissions suivre le fil
d'information politique et parlementaire
pour vivre la politique en temps réel
connectez vous et réagissez sur
publicsenat.fr
la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale a pris
possession du palet de marie de médicis
moi j'avais le sentiment ce soir là
qu'ils ont pris la bastille
nos amis sénateurs de l'ump n'accepte
pas bien l'idée que le sénat changent et
que ils ne sont plus majoritaires
un sénat à gauche pour la première fois
de son histoire un virage qui vient
bouleverser l'examen du budget texte
phare de l'année en repoussant le débat
sur la loi de finances vous vous asseyez
lourdement sur la constitution vous
privilégiez votre démagogie
électoraliste au détriment de l'intérêt
collectif au service des français vous
ne pouvez pas prétendre empêché à toute
force à chaque fois la majorité d'aller
jusqu'au vote
conséquence de l'alternance la gauche
obtient le poste de rapporteur du budget
une première en général non la mesure
que proposera le gouvernement dans la
loi de finances rectificative n'est pas
aussi juste que celle que je propose
mais les socialistes laissent à
l'opposition ump la présidence de la
commission des finances
une décision controversée qui va changer
la donne vous auriez tort de mépriser ce
qu'ils ont fait sincèrement lorsqu'on
train de travailler ensemble les deux
nouveaux protagonistes sont des habitués
mais leur rôle ont radicalement changé
difficile de l'arrêter nicole bricq
toute la journée elles courent suis pas
une vedette de cinéma - je suis pas
manquer quand levée c'est la première
femme à occuper le poste de rapporteur
du budget j'ai jamais eu mes fonctions
parce que j'étais une femme s'est ému
par ce que je sais ce que je fais je ne
fais pas partie d'une génération ou
montagnes man on mettait une fable même
si elle avait un beau sourire et s'est
du coup quand même assez historique wii
auront n'exagérons pas dans le bureau
qu'elle occupe depuis le mois d'octobre
vacances
nicole bricq n'a presque rien changé je
travaillerai dans un couloir
non non je fais pas attention je doute
qu'une fonction à la seule chose que
j'ai changé le tableau bon j'ai pris
dans le fond de la maison voilà il en
nettoyer la moquette les murs mais bon
ils n'auraient pas faisable
le projet né voilà qui suffit à camper
le personnage c'est une bosseuse elle
déjeune souvent dans son bureau en
consultant ses dossiers
ça prend du temps je pars tous les soirs
avec laquelle la pouge pas super bien
sûr le trouble euros j'étais une
provinciale au départ une époque où
c'était pas rien moi je parle de gt pas
une énarque donc je n'avais pas de
réseau
j'étais d'un milieu qui n'était pas figé
pas filles 2 je me suis toujours battu
pour qu'à un moment donné on is back
c'est elle
voilà reitman nous aura épaisse